okay everyone if YouTube is to be
trusted I am now live so welcome welcome
to the big show we went live at 6:30 the
first matchup actually doesn't take
place until 6:45 so we're just giving
you all some time to get in here and and
get ready get ready to rumble can you
have the tournament link in the chat I
can work on sign-in that one for you
although someone seems to have just
retracted their message which i think
might have had the tournament link in it
let's pull it up here let's pull it up
pull it pull it pull it up okay I've got
it
unless I'm told otherwise I'm gonna link
it to you because why not I think we are
good to go here what is the time control
it's a bit of a weird one today Aakash
thanks for the the question though the
time control this evening is actually
going to be 8 minutes with a two-second
increment so about half the time of
those normal pro chesley time controls
now we have no fewer than three matches
to play today so there are course for
chess clubs or chess institutes in this
round-robin match up here and we are
going to play one match against each of
them in each match actually lasts for
two rounds there are two rounds in each
match our players play one game with
each color hello - I'm a Doc's gamer
hello Lynn Speier hello Mahmood Singh
some familiar faces how long is this
tourney well we're gonna be here
actually for quite a bit I've got the
details pulled up here it looks like I'm
gonna have to pull up more details
there's so many details to be they had
to be sure the first round starts at
6:45 and I believe the last round starts
at 8:20 which would put the second round
beginning
the time of like seven twenty or so
seven thirty will say seven thirty seven
thirty five somewhere in there so each
round is looking to last around 40 to 45
minutes I think no longer than that
probably you're on 40 minutes for each
round and there are three rounds Caro is
playing with which club sorry
so the the round has not actually
started yet I'm just following the top
game here on chess comm we have ten
minutes until the round starts the big
name on our team is actually the one and
only
Jeffry Zhang we have Geoffrey Zhang
playing for us for the state on the
chess club shouldn't take a ton of time
it's gonna take a few hours yeah gonna
be here a few hours so two rounds of
eight plus two in each match and then
when those matches conclude we go on to
Round two against another another team
oh I see the confusion now Akash so it's
not a round robin in each match each
match against the other chess club
consists of two games the the round
robin is actually between the the clubs
so that means our club play as all the
other clubs want one time not all of our
players play all of their players that
would be obscene we'd be here for days
you know the format is hopefully in the
description other big news
like I said Jeffrey Zhang is on our team
we have quite a few players playing for
us as well below there we have some
really impressive players let me pull up
the roster here there is au 2400
requirement for the next four players
and we have national master force Chen
international master dorsa Derrick Shani
who of course has been on our lovely
channels for the past month or so as
Grandmaster in residence she will be
playing for us we also have national
master Julian Pro Lake Oh
Julian of course the man of the protest
League team of the st. Louis
Archbishop's who has done quite a bit
for us there we also have national
master Nicholas Rosenthal
I believe mr. Rosenthal is an aspiring
twitch streamer himself so be sure to
check him out and believe his name is
Froelich and some numbers that I can
never remember so Nick Rosenthal playing
you 2200 we have the best player on our
team future world champion Rachel Leigh
after that we have future world champion
candidate Luo Yi these two kids are
terrifying and they're gonna go really
far in life and they're gonna beat
everybody this today keep an eye on that
then we have Chess Club employee Eric
tkachenko who is getting a little bit
too old to be a future world champion
but I'm sure he has a very promising
chess career as well and then after him
we also have Alex Jang another local kid
who is a very impressive chess player
and will likely go very very far with
his chest career then we have au 2000
requirement with some other famous faces
Froelich 67 is Nick Rosenthal Thank You
Akash
we have been loop a local I guess he's a
little old to be be called a kid at this
point but he plays a lot of chess we
have the man in the shadows the the wolf
the wolf man Danny Machuca playing for
the new 2000 we also have the one and
only Arjun Arjun is on new 2000 as well
as Aiden a lot of kiddos on our team
this week you 1800 we have Vinny toddy
party
we have pratik new Molly with Erin Linn
and Michael Pugachev more players I
believe from our select chess program
for talented youths in the st. Louis
area use 1600 we have Schanke Lee who
who performed very well in the previous
match against San Francisco I believe he
went one-on-one with a player almost 400
points higher rated than I'm so
impressive stuff we have Ben Simon who
recently won our first-ever viewer
tournament of chess960 of chess960 Fame
Ben Simon we also have Nick risco
playing for us this week Chess Club
employee founder of chess openings
abridged on the YouTube channel we also
have Jacob Sanders who you may know from
his famous match against Dennis Larew
that was an incredible blitz bounty to
watch and then finally we have the you
1,400 section with four more players
from our select rest program that is of
course Isabel Isabel also known as
cupcake who played for us last match she
did very well and had me shouting the
word cupcake over and over again in
excitement because she kept winning
we have Felix Jiang we also have a Raja
Diwan and Jenna's song on our team to
round out the roster here and they will
all be playing for us in multiple
multiple games checking back in here we
have six minutes in 42 seconds until the
start six minutes to go and then we will
be on our way
any other questions about the format for
me before we get going here because once
we get going it's gonna be crazy the
time controls faster than the previous
match and there's I think even more
games or just as many games so it's
gonna be it's gonna be a fun one gonna
be tough to cover probably we're gonna
stick mostly with Geoffrey Zhang's game
because who doesn't love seeing
Jeffrey's young and beat up on people
okay
in the meantime it looks like a car is
still playing chess everybody loves car
other important information yet let's
see if I can pull up some more stuff
here regarding this online blitz match
so of course the four chest Institute's
in the match here
fortunately the engines not running out
crash so if it's it's being a bit slow I
can't really can't really help it here
mm-hmm
can't really help it I'll try closing
any and all tabs that I am not presently
really using see how I'm doing now I've
closed some stuff close some stuff
hopefully it's a bit better the other
chess club's chess centers chess
institutes what-have-you in this match
are of course the San Francisco
mechanics they are coming back for more
after we destroyed them in the previous
match we also have the Marshall chess
club playing this week as well as the
Charlotte chess Center so a lot of the
top chess centers and clubs or
Institute's what-have-you in the country
for chess all in this event so we'll
definitely be looking to to take them on
down no prize money this time around
just bragging rights and of course the
st. Louis chess club is all about
getting bragging rights and we will be
playing our utmost best year to try and
win these matches
yes the Marshall chess club in the
Marshall chess club and looking at the
Marshall chest clip it looks like they
have a GM sorry looking at the Mechanics
Institute rather it looks like they have
a GM already in the in the match
Jim tar John I don't know Tim Joe I I
don't know how to say his name either
looks kind of like Tarzan but with a J
they have a grandmaster on their top
board let me google this guy's see what
we're working with here see what we're
working with is this is he like famous
okay so his rating is actually under
twenty four hundred so they might have a
another ringer coming in on board one
this guy might not be their board one
because he qualifies for you twenty four
hundred I believe
Carlo and the French player that's in
tars on the legend ya parently he was
like famous I don't know my my us chess
history unfortunately I'm embarrassed
I've been embarrassed
I'm not playing because Mike thinks I'm
a better commentator than I am a player
and he might be right
any standard viewer attorneys in the
future so we loved doing the chess960
tournament
I had a great turnout over a hundred
people ended up playing in that one and
so we're definitely looking to do more
of those I think on a regular basis but
nothing's scheduled just yet nothing
scheduled just yet two minutes in 40
seconds to start this tournament and I'm
getting a little NIT a little bit
nervous because I am uh not seeing I
repeat I am not yet seeing Jeffrey's
young in the event which is terrifying
he recently had a tournament where he
beat kramnik Wow okay I should probably
know about this guy
face all of the jungle not only Tarzan
alright Mike hasn't seen Queen takes d4
and that's that's right maybe I should
show him that game I don't know I don't
know how to convince Mike to put me on
one of these teams like I play in a
Saturday night special I beat all the
Webster GM's he's still not impressed
just can't get this guy to get me on the
team beat unis asking Quesada Perez not
enough not good enough not good enough
you beat a romhack Obion World Youth
champion not enough can't beat that guy
not on the team yes but I gotta talk
about the games maybe someday when will
it begin we have one minute in 30
seconds till the start of the event
Tarzan Tarzan okay runs with Tarzan
Tartt Tarzan Tarzan it looks like a
car's got an ape on here it seems pretty
good
one minute to the start of the event
here once again this is the first match
of the event there are three matches
total first up is the San Francisco
mechanics chess club we are squaring off
against them and then we will be facing
either the Marshall chess club or the
Charlotte chess Center but by the end of
it we'll have played everybody and
hopefully have beaten everybody
tournament link I'm gonna link it to you
after it's already in progress cuz I
don't want to mess anything up I don't
know if I can mess anything up but
either way I don't want to mess anything
up note there are 39 seconds to the
start of this tournament and I still do
not see Geoffrey Jean here which is
terrifying we need that guy commentating
on a specific player um it just depends
on how interesting the games are likely
I'll have one game that that is kind of
my focus so hopefully Geoffrey Zhang's
game but then I'll likely skip around to
a few other boards and maybe follow all
their games it's gonna be a long night
thank you I'm a Doc's thank you doing
good something simple doing well eight
seconds to the start this event
here we go on our way all right there's
the tournament link Oh
I'm apparently not allowed to post the
tournament link unfortunate unfortunate
it looks like the games are officially
in progress now Geoffrey Zhang is not
here so looks like Nick Rosenthal is
taking board one for the first round
we'll see how well he does here uh yeah
all right Nick Rosenthal against
legendary Tim Tarja tart Tarzan Tarzan
I'm told let's see what's going on here
looks like an Italian game looks like an
Italian in the meantime we also have
dorsa playing dorsa hates when you watch
her games so we'll be sure to keep an
eye on this game as well I think we're
gonna focus on these two for the first
round and see how well we do see how
well we do so so far in Italian Nick
Rosenthal just taking it pretty pretty
simply here I place D 3 plates III
eventually it's gonna look to play a
move like D for just the normal normal
Italian plans bring this Bishop out to
e3 or g5
bring this Knight out to D to play rook
e1 bring the knight to g3 things like
that the things you have hopefully
hopefully seen hundreds of times before
everybody loves these yoco piano and we
have black actually breaking in the
center pretty early on with d5 before
white ever gets a chance to uh to play
these kinds of things so now the problem
with d5 is it always leaves this epon
feeling just a little bit weak
now you might make fun of me for not
knowing all of the theory here but
that's that's kind of the idea you know
I don't know the specifics on how blacks
supposed to defend this pawn but this
pawn just feels a little bit weak with
the open e file now and no D pawn to
support it it's also a little bit tough
to play the move f6 here because you
open up this diagonal in front of your
king so Bishop g4 nicely looks to remove
an attacker from this epon looks like
now black is committed to taking on f3
if black stuffs up you might even see a
g5 move then a fish of g6
suddenly this pawn on e5 is gonna fall
so I think Bishop takes f3 is the move
here unless o we do see Bishop f5 well
or Bishop h5 rather will white go for
this g4 move I wonder it looks a little
bit shaky a little bit shaky too weak in
the Kings side like this but I mean a
pawn is a pawn this is NIC Rosenthal's
decision early on what will he do here
what will he do of course black is going
to get some compensation for this pun if
you do play g4 bishop g6 and Knight
takes e5 well already there's probably
moves like Bishop d6 although you can't
really leave this night behind so g4
bishop g6 is definitely gonna be the
main variation that Nick is thinking
about here if he doesn't like it you can
just kind of go back to simple chess
with 92 but he goes for g4 and I think
this is good for white to be honest with
you I don't see why white shouldn't just
take this free pawn on e5 and this is
Nick Rosenthal's idea if you play g4
you're definitely taking on e5 and we'll
see what Jim Tarzan Tarzan had in mind
so can't see that guy's name I'm the
worst grand mechanic gran mechanic
Grandmaster all the general all the
grants maybe also general manager I
don't know I don't know nothing about
nothing this Bishop looks like it's
attacked probably we need to move it out
of the way and I guess this is Jim's
simple idea here you just wants to put a
bishop on d6 and go for go for this
pressure on these newly weakened squares
on on the Kings side I suppose 92 is
worth considering as well it hangs deep
3 though so I don't really like it maybe
Queen e2 is the move that Nick is
thinking about but you're really just
taking away retreating squares premiere
from your rook at that point I think
Bishop e3 should be played I think Nick
should also pick up the pace a little
bit it's definitely a complex position
and we're spending a little bit of time
but it's game in 8 minutes here you have
to have to go
best okay somehow we've already scored a
point though how did we already scored a
point I don't understand we're up one to
nothing and the match just started okay
I don't see any wins for us actually
okay here we go
it's just come on the screen Nick risco
has actually already won his game
Nick risco with the first blood of the
match here well Nick is thinking why
don't we see how Nick won his game so
quickly oh okay it looks like I figured
out how Nick won is game so quickly here
you play Queen D Queen B for after
castles and black missed it that's a
checkmate good job - Nick drawing first
blood in this event
okay Queen f3 by Nick Rosenthal here I
guess I like this myth a little bit it's
a bit more active than just drawing the
bishop back Nick isn't worried so much
about takes and takes although maybe I
am this was actually a really important
Bishop and maybe I would have liked it
to keep it I guess the problem is that
this pawn simply Hanks if you do play
Bishop III so Nick is trying to hold on
to the extra pawn here it's gonna come
at the expect the expense of some
activity though these two bishops are
gonna become very very active and why
it's gonna have to really keep track of
those so we do see Knight takes and pond
takes
in the question now for white is can he
developed this queenside if white gets
fully developed gets moves like Bishop
f4 it was like 92 and 9f one in and
especially bringing this other right to
the center then I think white should be
doing just fine up the pawn but black
has a few moves to decide what he wants
to do he needs to take pretty immediate
advantage of this leaden development
here or else white is simply going to
get developed going to consolidate and
will be up one extra pawn so Bishop d6
rook e1 makes the most sense
maybe rook e8 now by black but it would
be met with a timely Bishop e3 when 92
is is difficult to stop
perhaps nick is in fact getting
developed now of course it's not so
simple it's just an easy extra pawn here
as black does have the two bishops and
white has created a few weaknesses
around the King yeah very very dangerous
stuff here let's check in on Dorset camp
let's see we had of course the classical
nimzo-indian and Dorsett took a
conservative approach to the center not
going crazy with stuff like efore just
III and guard all your centrist center
squares get castled and now e5 from
black like fighting for the dark squares
95 comes on the board now the white is
no longer pinned and a4 from black I'm
really uh oh okay I got the colors wrong
dorsa has black
okay so black dorsa goes now for c5 with
the dark square approach but isn't the
pawn on e5 just hanging I really wonder
isn't the pawn on e5 hanging for free
doors so what happened I guess you just
can't play a c5 here why why okay well
the Knights hanging so you have to play
c5 so I guess it was all just misguided
here a4 seemed weird was weird and might
now just be be losing a pawn
to uh tonight take c5 here unless dorsa
has like some tricks like you can't play
Knight takes his 94 but yes simply Queen
takes
and now III don't see anything better
than taking back and white is going to
be upon the good it's checking checking
back in on Nick now he really needs to
pick up the pace
Bishop III is a very natural move and I
think it should be played just quite
quickly I'm now noticing that Bishop g4
is likely the problem Bishop b4 is is
probably giving giving Nick some some
pause here so he goes for rook rook III
instead okay but now simply a Bishop c5
I think it's going to come and there's
no way to maintain this rook on this
file
maybe Bishop c5 here Bishop c5 take take
then Bishop e3 then there's still a
Bishop e4 I don't know queen g3 there
Queen D whoa it just looks looks awkward
looks quite awkward you have to block
this file or else you're gonna get
killed by Queen e1 I guess Knight d2
might be playable but yet this should be
through the most natural now and now now
this move I think the response has to be
Queen g3 and against Bishop d6 can you
really play Bishop f4 I'm wondering it's
hanging by a thread here for Nick
Rosenthal hanging by a thread
hanging by a thread
we see the Grandmaster actually just
take this bishop off on e3 and I don't
know if I agree with this decision
what he's doing is simply going in for a
better endgame queen takes you can
expect to see Queen takes pawn takes and
then I move like rook da and the point
is while you develop this Knight the
circuits into 2d - it does just feel
like you might have sell sold his
position a little bit short
I actually think Nick was in quite a bit
of trouble with these two bishops raking
across the board and this endgame is
definitely not the worst thing to ever
happen to the white pieces white does
for the moment maintain his extra pawn
yeah and the score is actually up to
four to one why don't we see where these
results are coming from first of all I
expect b3 here might be five is also a
consideration but but why not just play
b3 well actually I think you have to
play Knight b5 I take it all back if you
play b3 gonna move like a six oh gosh
okay b4 is trying to respond to a six
with b5 or maybe maybe even c5 yeah okay
so this is the point I was worried about
this night getting trapped but c5 and 9c
for business plan in the meantime it
looks like unfortunately Vinnie has lost
his first game to WCM Harker chess in
the meantime wow we have a player who
has defeated his opponent in both games
already
who is PR chess 2016 I wonder what
player is right below new crisco I don't
have all the players chess calm
usernames so it's a little bit tough for
me on occasion do you figure out who is
who
but whoever PR chess 2016 is he just
destroyed Daniel Pearl off in both games
easy - oh and Jenna Jenna song has also
won her first game so we are dominating
them on the lower boards right now b3
rook d4 I I don't understand I don't
understand what Rick d4 is maybe you met
Brooke d3 yeah Brooke d3 I'm not so
worried about giving the pawn back here
I'm not I'm not as worried about that
it's about getting these pieces in the
game and yeah he's actually still going
for some kind of attack now
Knight c4 there's a check King f1 will
have to be played and you have to be a
little bit wary of this Technol just a
little bit careful and wait a second no
no this is just dead right this is just
dead white is losing an exchange at the
very least Rick h1 is a powerful threat
rook h1 is a powerful threat you have to
play your key one to guard the deep
three square but then wreck h1 King e2
and Bishop f3 is at least winning in
exchange potentially more potentially
more looks like this one is not going
next wait you have to play your if d1
here there's no other move and then rook
h1 and Bishop f3 is enough to to win
material be nicer to my knuckles sorry
sorry Brian
I try oh but that's just okay so this is
trying to respond to Bishop d3 with king
g1 but something should be wrong here
something should be wrong something must
be wrong
something must be wrong here if nothing
else check King g1 and rook takes h3
Nick's putting up a fight though making
him work for it making them work for it
and it takes h3 first but now perhaps
the white pieces are in fact going to
get into the game
definitely still a tough and game for
Nick he's been a bit on the back foot
ever since first capturing that pawn
okay now g5 comes on the board
I suppose Rick d1 will be the next move
I think black is still somehow trying to
checkmate white which is it's a little
bit funny black though also just makes
lift with g5 and prepares to make some
past ponce with that I move like age
five age five might actually be played
immediately he gives the check instead
king g3 is forest rip g2 puts the King
in a box but perhaps district takes a
two now probably just or takes a - okay
Rick G - and then Rick takes a two might
be an improvement
if you don't move this rook then rook d4
it's gonna come on the board and this
Bishop is gonna get harassed no matter
where it goes
ninety-five will make sure this bishop
can't stay connected to the rook
so rook takes a two seems like the only
move perhaps he's thinking about h5 now
actually h5 is interesting
threatens checkmate so it's a pretty
immediate threat that you have to look
out for ninety-five might be played but
that runs into f6 but that runs into
rook here then takes takes it's looking
a little bit hairy
so rook takes a two instead not going
for those crazy lines now I expect to
move like rook d7 to come on the board
work d7 might be played but once again
h5 threats are going to come could also
play a move like rook d4 here if you're
really worried about the location of
this Bishop make this bishop move around
a little bit likely it'll come back to
c6 where it can keep an eye in the d7
square so Nick just goes for this
immediately instead now 95 is a threat
rook takes C 7 is a threat he's battling
back here
he's definitely battling back
and now Jim taking his time okay rook c2
goes after the c3 pawn and then
immediately afterwards it will go after
the e3 pawn as well I expect them 95
note from a Nick Bishop g6 must be
blacks idea to stop her it takes f7 I
don't think you you can really just play
rook takes c3 in response will take f7
will take c7 okay he goes for this now
but this gives up this gives up quite a
lot actually now whenever you play
Knight d6 or 95 there's Bishop d5 and g6
is a much worse Square then then d5 is
so actually though okay there's just
Knight takes b7 I keep doubting Nick but
Nick seems to uh seems to be finding
finding ways to survive if a knight
takes three seven is gonna be quite
risky actually for uh for black oh my
gosh what all right Nick Rosenthal's the
best never doubted him never doubted him
and dorsa seems to have drawn her first
game actually with her opponent and is
in her second game so well done to dorsa
thought that game actually looked a
little bit tough for her going down that
pawn let's see how that actually ended
up so we left off here Knight c2 was the
idea rook be one night back to b4 and
she simply collects this a to pawn
interesting and then from there she got
active got the rooks in and managed to
draw this endgame well done to dorsa
back to this game Nick Rosenthal is now
up a rook so think he's doing well why
don't we check in on our board too which
is of course
Julian Crowe lekha I expect Nick to win
this game easily okay Julian with the
black pieces here against webkinz never
doubt a knight it's a good point that's
a good point
Julian also seems to be down a little
bit of material here down upon and this
e pawn for white is quite frightening
I find myself quite frightened by it
but he does have a strong bishop on d4
in an act of reckon on g1 now I'm white
I'm calculating e6 here this is the main
move you have to have to be calculating
if yz6 wins then you play it if it
doesn't then you don't
so King d5 instead I don't think he's
six was a good move so well done to
webkinz now e six does come on the board
since this king has removed itself from
the threat of the check yeah Bishop e7
is trying to hold on to this pawn but
now that the King gets to d7 and this is
looking tough looking tough I think the
best that black can hope for here is
trying to sacrifice this bishop and and
get into some kind of endgame that's not
totally lost be seven now wins wins the
bishop by force so I think e7 should be
played and the Sun game should be lost
unfortunately for Julian I really don't
know why you seven isn't being played
perhaps he's calculating route takes f6
but yeah just just east seven here just
e7 simple enough you have to give up the
bishop nothing else and it's it's gonna
be a loss unless Julian somehow swindles
his way into a draw here but I don't
expect it dorsa unfortunately lost her
second game somehow someway dorsa
resigned to his position I'm confused
what happened why did dorsa resign this
position what the heck
is that true
94 white resigns what's going on here I
think some some misclick I don't know
very strange stuff from dorsa the total
match score now is 14 and a half to end
to eight and a half and take note here
the match score is actually going to be
really relevant the total scoring is not
done by how many matches you win but
rather your game points in each match so
we want to kill them as much as we can
score as many points as possible I also
wanted to mention that I think who is
this player Forrest Chen I think Forrest
Chen has also won his first game as Nick
Rosenthal did as well scoring a full
point against the legend Jim Tarzan okay
who do we want to follow why don't we
follow someone new why don't we follow
someone new let's see how Forrest Chen
is doing in this game as well he has the
black piece of serious off flip the
board it looks like he's doing a ok I
think I like blacks position here
material is even black has this weakness
on e6 but white has this weakness on f2
both sides with a half-open file
kind of compensation this Bishop on f7
is doing a great job of holding down
this weakness expect black to play e5 in
the near future
Black's gonna play e5 I'm gonna bring
this Knight out to to e5 and break down
the support on this F pile getting rid
of his only weakness
I'm around 2,200 Rahul Tingler had
accidentally resigned against MVL today
that is crazy
Missy Sh that is crazy okay
so White's trying to figure out how he's
going to stop a five
I don't think white can stop a five and
this is likely the problem with his
position
u5 though there are some weird tactics
you have to look out for Bishop f5
looking at looking at this guy on d7
something like e for Bishop takes Knight
and it's getting a little bit
complicated so I'm not totally convinced
black can play e5 immediately the ship
f5 there might be Bishop e6 but then
your Queens going to be opposite this
rook here that's going to be tough
going to be tough so I'm sure forest is
calculating b5 now
I'm sorry back to the match score here
the total score is now 14 and a half to
10 1/2 there are 50 total points up for
grabs in this match there's 25 games and
2 or sorry 25 players on our team and
two games each let me just do a quick
count because we do seem to be missing
Jeffrey's young make sure everybody make
sure we still have 25 that's five there
seven nine ten eleven twelve thirteen
fourteen nineteen twenty twenty-one
twenty-two twenty-three twenty-four so
there's only 24 players in the match as
Jeffrey Zhang did not seem to make it in
time so that means 48 points up for
grabs rather than the original 50
so 48 points total that we could score
and the score is now 15 half to 11 half
so to get a majority we are going to
need 24 total points 24 and a half
rather so it looks like ie 5 was played
white did not actually go for this
Bishop f5 line I wonder why I think this
was the main problem with E 5 but rather
the players simply took on e5
now black with two bishops pressure on
the F file pressure on the b-pawn is I
think just going to be doing quite well
in this game in fact I believe black is
as close to winning here close to
winning with this positional advantage
Knight f3 is holding on to everything
blocking this file and defending
laterally here so Bishop d6 instead
ah I see dorsa that is a shame that is a
shame
okay we have Bishop d6 so yeah black is
just gonna sit on this - bishop
advantage bring the rooks into the game
perhaps rick c8 will come on the board
next Bishop c5 is also an idea to start
attacking this guy even crazy stuff like
g4 g5 might come on the board just to
shake loose this knight black white
seems to be taking control of the e-file
but these bishops do a really great job
of guarding all of the entry squares so
not the most threatening thing going on
here with these rooks bishops e5 is
blacks choice once again just putting
more pressure on f2 I'd really like to
see a way to activate this bishop and
for that reason you might expect to see
a move like Bishop h5 coming soon Bishop
f5 hits this rook rook da helps support
the isolated pawn
yeah there are more rounds dorsa there
are more rounds Bishop e6 is on the
board we can take this bishop if we want
ripped it rook to e6 is going to come on
the board so white is neutralizing the
two bishops here but the dark squared
bishop that remains is going to be quite
strong going to be quite strong for
black I really like forests position
here jumping back in let's check back in
on our board one Nick Rosenthal here it
looks like this is not gonna be it for
white actually nick has black I always
mess this up I don't know why they put
our players at the top sometimes but
okay well I dunno why it's because they
have the the black pieces but this is
looking really dangerous for for white
here Knight to d5 is trying to trade off
this e3 night if Queen tix g3 we are
threatening the f2 rook if Knight takes
III simply queen tix f2 and I think that
looks quite good for for black this line
so Queen takes g3 I wonder if King g1 is
going to be the move however King g1
seems to allow Knight g4 with with other
threats so we do see this line come on
the board I think now white might have
to take this Knight but the problem for
white is even by giving this material
back here you're not really getting rid
of the attack you're still gonna be
under quite a lot of pressure and I
don't see a way out for for white here I
think Nick Rosenthal is doing a really
great job against the Grandmaster and
might be walking away with two points
so yeah we've night takes III not Queen
takes f2 will be played
Knight takes g2 is the best move I'm not
so convinced because 9 takes g2 doesn't
really actually make any threats the
squares defended enough time simply
simply king takes I think so I like the
way Nick played it here tonight takes c3
gotta be Queen takes f2 I don't know
what uh what else Nick is considering if
you play rook takes c3 I don't think you
have a checkmate there see a queen f2
comes on the board taking off the truck
now this Knight is in fact hanging there
are still threats like Queen h4 this
Bishop still is on the board guarding
the G 1 square and directly expect to
see black 2 to bring the other rooks
into the game and I think this is just
gonna be a crush I think this is gonna
be a crush so Knight a5 I expect you're
a to d8 now just getting more rooks in
the game white okay white might be
playing rook f1 next turn though and
this could be an issue for us if we
don't give our Queen
any flight squares so maybe this is what
Nick has to deal with no Rick d8 and now
it's rook f1 what is what is his idea
what's the plan here I don't see it
okay it looks a little strange but maybe
simply Bishop takes d4 in that case if
rook takes F to Bishop takes f2 and we
have a very strange material imbalance
that is slightly in White's favor but a
Frick d1 check comes on the board I
think it might just be winning we'll see
we'll see rook f1 has to be the try here
I'm not sure what else can be played if
not Regev one rook f1 there might be
rookie two tactics but but simply Queen
take c2 I think is enough to make you
reject that line
you know Ciroc f1 comes on the board now
we shall see Knicks plan we shall see I
think this Bishop takes d4 might be the
best might be the best we can do here
okay maybe maybe rook takes you to Queen
takes you to Queen takes e2 Knight takes
you to Bishop takes you to rook
somewhere and rip here it's just just
down a full piece there unfortunately
just gonna be down a full piece if you
go for that line maybe Queen takes e2
yeah simply Queen takes you to you guys
are right that that one does seem to
hold everything together for some reason
I didn't consider this one now you don't
lose the exchange back you can just take
that with the bishop on e 2 rather than
with the rook and so black is holding on
to the material so what are we left with
after Bishop takes e2 well it looks like
there is a g7 pawn hanging
I'm so confused all the time
my life is so confusing there's a g7
pond but but what but what but rook d2
if you take g7 then probably rook d2 d2
and you're crashing through on the
second rank
boom wasted all right got him Talia's
calling it
Talia's calling it you have to take this
bishop money - I don't know what the the
big Grand Master is thinking about here
if you don't take this bishop I don't
think you you can sir you can win this
game the match scores up to 19 to 15 in
our favor he says simply a lot I I kind
of do actually maybe it's a problem rook
c1 instead I I don't I don't believe it
you can't leave can't leave black with
these bishops I guess he's trying to
keep more pieces on the board keep
chances alive but this Bishop on e2 is
going to be a good piece for black
okay just takes just takes b7 does g6
win or does g6 is g6 of losing attempt
g6 night h6 King g7 perhaps and they
take c2 Knight takes h6 okay Nick's not
having it not having it just plays
Bishop d3 just plays Bishop d3 I like it
I think black has too many extra pawns
here on on the Kings side for white to
be surviving this like has too many
pawns and that the king is too safe okay
maybe now Bishop e4 check just to give
this Rick a square and start making a
threat
two nights for whiter tricky though
that's fair enough I really like this
move Bishop e4 just get get rid of this
life's great bishop I know I said whites
should have taken on you two to get rid
of this Bishop but now I think it's
black who wants to get rid of rid of
this bishop with with Bishop e4
this move is check you have to take or I
guess you can move but then I'll simply
take here simply and come crashing
through Bishop takes d4 instead okay so
this is just attempting to trade even
more pieces I still think Bishop b4 is
gonna come on the board black is kind of
just trading down here this should be
for I like quite a bit
we have takes and takes
okay f4 is hanging so knight c6 if you
play your xe8 you lose the game so don't
play rook c8 and then you don't lose the
game okay rookie it's good you got to
keep an eye on this back rank for the
moment that's kind of why it's only a
trick I expect to move f6 to come soon
taking away the e5 square from both
bishop and in the night and then you can
start thinking about things like or it
takes that for don't play York takes up
4 here 97 might be a little bit awkward
well if you take 97 King of fate or even
King h8 maybe you can just take this
pawn maybe that's just a pawn
nick does in fact capture and White
doesn't even go from 97 the the Chiefs
the the tricks are too cheap here the
tricks are too cheap for for white to
play ok now moves like like checks
starts become interesting if I'm the
black player here I'm trying to check me
at white I think easiest might might
simply just be pushing simply
just gotta push these pawns okay white
in the meantime though is going to be
trying to push with b5 b6 since this is
a little bit fast this is this is a
little bit too fast for it for my taste
this looks a little bit scary over there
so what do we do
rook g6 seems to make a threat rook g6
simply b5 simply then check here take
stakes are you stopping this pawn are
you stopping this pawn I'm not so sure
not so sure
King h7 I don't know about King age 7
seems a little slow seems a little slow
here
ah okay this move no not that move okay
Oh No
Oh God okay well next Donna don't down a
bishop now unfortunately this box is not
true because white steps here next time
and is just gonna gonna promote that's
that's not so good that's not so good
what went wrong this beep on just came
out of nowhere
beep on just came out of nowhere I think
this move
I think this move giving up this a pawn
was a little bit too friendly I think
just a little bit too friendly and nick
has in fact resigned this game note
though we are already up to 26 points
which is enough for a majority in this
match but a majority is not good enough
we need more points let's check in on
Julian for lejos game who is looking for
revenge against webkinz here looks like
his position is pretty decent here I
think white is doing quite well black of
course cannot allow it for the rook
trade because then the white king is
going to get very very active and may
end up just just winning the game for
example if the rooks trade then King III
king d4 and the game is more or less
over so it looks like they go for a
repetition here Julian unwilling to
allow this trick to get active black
unwilling to allow the King to get
active ends up just being a draw okay
looks like most of the games have
actually already been decided
note that forest has actually won both
of his games we had that unfortunate
resignation from dorsa wolf team 2018
has one and a half out of two eric has
one and one unfortunately unforced
errors lost both games Arjun seems to
have only scored a half point but no
worries there and it looks like the next
best game in progress is this game by
Luke
ye luke ye with the white pieces here
seems to be trying to hold a draw we'll
see if he succeeds in his quest here to
hold a draw in this position this is
looking dangerous looking quite
dangerous
opposite colored bishops are going to be
White's only hope in this case if white
can somehow hold a miracle draw that's
going to be with because of the opposite
colored bishops so look to expect black
or sorry to expect white to set up some
kind of dark square blockade here this
move feels wrong I think you simply
should should just take simply very
simply and then and then bring the King
in with something like King d5 but
instead we have this position now if I'm
white I'm a hundred percent going to
take on g5 okay Bishop b2 instead not
takes on g5 interesting so Bishop b2 is
keeping an eye on this pawn and Bishop
c3 will come next and now because black
brought the King back to f7
honestly I like whites holding chances a
lot more a big problem is this pawn here
on g4 being stuck in a light square but
I think with the King on f3 okay you
have to take this this bishop comes to
c3 now I don't know what the black King
is doing over here to be honest I don't
know what's going on with this okay it's
it's shuffle time for poor white here
shuffle with the bishop wait for f5 I
suppose and blacks should definitely
start putting this okay f5 is ridiculous
what's what is a5 Bishop c3 now and you
have to play a four and then it's all
the more difficult to start pushing
those pawns Wow b4 so this is a little
bit too friendly giving up a pawn here
or not giving up a pawn wellyes giving
up a pawn but not recapturing now a for
this this b-pawn is going to be
something for a black tube to worry
about
this is by it by no means even close to
winning now for for black no way black
wins this game at this point
why does shuffles Bishop a1 bishop c3
and it's it's over
and it should be over okay Bishop a1
does the black King get in I don't think
so
I hope not if King d5 here just expect
to see the move King III I would expect
King III anyways actually just stay stay
calm stay safe
King III and yeah now King D 4 is gonna
come unless you play King D 5 and that
simply just gives up this time so yeah
bishop picks up six now and is white
even worse I don't think so
is white playing for a win white might
be playing for a win
oh my gosh obviously the position is a
dead drop but now it seems like white
spawns are the more threatening ones
okay what is this he wants to trade a
trade off these pawns this is black kind
of giving up should just be a draw now
just under off the nice part of this
position is you put the King on a1 and
then you sacrifice your bishop but then
you sacrifice your pawn and then you can
pre move the rest of the game hello
Matthew
hello and hello to Savannah alright that
is a drop and now I believe that might
have been the last game note there that
is in fact the last game of the match we
win by eight points in this one getting
28 of 48 possible points here so not a
bad start at all from the st. Louis team
I feel like the strategy here is just
going to be get solid scores against all
the teams you don't have to try to kill
them but
due to the format of this event of
course sorry I'm getting distracted here
trying to set things up due to the
format of this event it is really
critical to score as many points as
possible in each round the games the the
total score rather is not determined by
whether or not you win the match but by
your total game points scored so our
score so far is 28 it's curious I'm
actually curious what score the other
teams have and I'm gonna find out right
now I'm gonna find out hopefully I can
do it hopefully I can do it it looks
like what does it look like what does it
look like oh it looks like the Charlotte
chess Center is actually beating us by a
point after the first round Charlotte
scored one point better against the
Marshall chess club than we did against
our around one opponent the San
Francisco mechanics so the Marshall
chess club right now has 19 points
the Charlotte chess Center has 29 so we
are a point back and it I guess it seems
like the Charlotte chess Center is going
to be the team to beat going into the
final round and they are our final round
opponent so it'll be really interesting
to see to see that last round match up
it should be a battle for first place if
all goes well against the Marshall chess
club here can't access the other match I
believe this is the match here I can't
put links in the chat let me try let me
try here let me try here
okay I can't do it I can't link you the
match but trust me it is 29 to 19 in
that other match we now have seven
minutes for a little bit of a break in
between this match in the next one so we
shall see what we can do here it looks
like we do finally have Jeffrey Zhang in
the match note that we won that last
match 28 to 20 without Jeffrey we didn't
need them Nik Rosenthal on board one
went 1 and 1 and scored enough points
for us ok did not need Jeffrey in round
1 so think of how many points we're
gonna score with Jeffrey here hopefully
two more put points in now I'm not gonna
not gonna bother below not gonna bother
the score so far of course is 28 for us
29 for Charlotte and 19 for the
Marshalls of course that leaves the San
Francisco mechanics with 20 points so
like I said Charlotte chess sin are
going to be the team to beat here I
think going to be the team to beat first
though we have to kind of prove our
worth against the Marshall chess club
have to prove our worth hmm
so who is real boy let's find out who
are you real boy who is bored one for
the Marshall chess club looks like
grandmaster Kamra cool of Jura Beck from
Uzbekistan now living in New York very
unclear let's let's Google him let's
let's spell his name right hopefully
let's google them head hurts but you
wanna watch this match everybody does
everybody does looks like this guy's
feet I reading is just over 2500 should
be no match for 2700 plus player Jeffrey
Zhang although who is a match for
Jeffrey Zhang these days nobody
absolutely nobody unless you got Magnus
Carlsen on your team good luck
so we have a 5 minute 5 minutes left
until this one gets started here
Marshall will be looking for better
performance yeah they're definitely
going to be looking to it to come back a
little bit stronger than they looked in
that first first match where they only
scored 19 points be on the lookout in
this this time around for dorsa who
hopefully will no longer resign by
mistake that was a problem in the first
match
just think if Dorsett didn't
accidentally resign her game we could be
tied for first right now couldn't be
tied first every point matters every
point matters
and a us you have rated tournaments
online I believe they have an online
rating for us CF and there are ways to
to organize those tournaments but it's
it's kind of crazy stuff but I don't
know if that's something we're looking
to do okay just patiently awaiting this
round to get underway here ah
Aradia yes because you might not get an
opponent oh you probably will if all
goes well you will
yeah Marshall is the main Manhattan
chess club that's that is accurate it's
the big New York New York club it's the
big one
all right three minutes to go and it
looks like the Marshall chess club is
missing two players so that's good news
that's good news it seemed like the
lower boards we're really where we
excelled in that past match we were kind
of doing quite well on the lower board
so we'll look to do that again here note
that just because we have Geoffrey Zhang
doesn't mean we're just gonna kill the
kill the match here because Geoffrey can
only score maximum of two points for us
and that's just not enough to win a
match
ah thank you Savannah Manhattan for the
$1 thank you thank you
okay two minutes to the start here two
minutes to the start of course I will be
following in Geoffrey Zhang to start
with going to be really interesting
matchup here against this sorry it was
it was Becca Stan Rebecca Stanny looks
like who's Becca Stan this is Becca
Stanny Grandmaster
just a minute 30 to go there's no I in
team but there is I in quarantine it's a
good thing that's a good thing all right
who else should we follow who do we do
do you think we should we should be
following hear a wolf team 2018 that's
Rachel Lee of course chess-playing wolf
and that is Danny Machuca I always get
them confused I always get them confused
very confusing stuff we have two wolves
on the st. Louis chess club team is the
best way to find out what your rank is
you have to play chess and then you just
get a rating that's all you have to do
just got to play some chess
oh my goodness Savannah with the $2
doubling the donation what is it with
all the Wolves I don't know wolves just
seem to be popular chess names I think
Danni has another account that's like a
dragon or something he's just very into
these mythical beasts Bishop's are
generally better in my opinion depending
on the position of course okay three two
one
looks like we are underway officially
keeping an eye on Jeffries youngest game
here looks like we have a Cairo
oh and Jeffrey is playing on the fantasy
variation really interesting stuff here
unfortunate Arad yes sorry to hear that
sorry to hear that sorry to hear it okay
f3 on the board and real boy is stunned
he is stunned by the fantasy variation
from Jeffrey Zhang doesn't know what to
do he's 6 okay this is not my favorite
line by black against the fantasy
variation why are you playing the
CARICOM if you're just gonna do this I
don't understand
spending that $1,200 in the right way of
course b6 now okay a three is simple
enough we'll take that with the night
III assume on c3 just supporting the
center here b6 from black is hinting
that black wants to trade off these
lights great bishops and in this manner
and I suppose this makes some sense I
suppose this makes a little bit of sense
here black or white now is probably
gonna look - I believe take on a six and
then just develop this Bishop out to a
square like e3 or a square like f4 and
with one extra Bishop life should
actually be pretty good learn how to
crush the carrot well this one doesn't
count
because black played a bad line but I
played a bad line white doesn't have to
play such a bad line so I think White's
position is just a little bit better
White has this nice dark squared Bishop
and black has all these nice dark
squared weaknesses and black has no dark
squared Bishop to compensate for them so
just a comfortable edge for Jeffrey in
the meantime though black is going to be
looking to force white to play a move
like a 5v5 really isn't a move that
white is interested in playing here
because it stunts this Bishop makes this
bishop look a lot less impressive
so Knight f6 pressures efore trying to
tempt white in a plane e5 of course
Jeffrey declines no expect white to
Queens like Castle bring more rooks to
the center of the board or even
potentially and go for some King side
pawn pushes Jeffrey's sf3 than f3 it is
in the meantime due to this maneuver
with Bishop a6 and Knight takes a six
it's true that white got rid of our
black get rid of White's great
LightSquared Bishop but now this Knight
is a little bit misplaced so I expect to
see this Knight actually come back to be
8 and into d7 or c6
at a later date so this noggin a6 just
doesn't nothing so as I said black
castles King side and now expect to see
a white go for some pushes over here
likely going to be combined with a queen
side castles at some point simply F
takes c4 I would assume I don't see why
not
but Jeffery taking a moment
taking a quick little pause and now c5
from black was the point of his play I
suppose with this night on a6
interesting that that Geoffrey just
allows tix on d4 so he goes in for a
better endgame now where he's going to
have more control of this D file and
this Bishop is in fact going to be a
really relevant piece here that's black
has to worry about I kind of like this
for Geoffrey
these strong grandmasters seem to really
play these end games well I don't know
what it is about them a quick look on
Doris's game why don't we check it out
why don't we see how horse is doing with
the black pieces looks like she is doing
absolutely fine it was one of those
Queen's Indian type of positions where
black has achieved both d5 and c5 and
once you get these two moves and it's
sometimes slightly awkward to organize
the pieces but if you manage to get
organized
then black should have no issues here 9
c6 aims to capture this and some women
expect to see the rooks come to the
center and black to keep everything
under control we might end up in what's
called the hanging pawn structure where
white has these two pawns connected on
the fourth rank and they do a great job
of limiting the black pieces they can
also become a bit weak if they're not
careful okay back to the action here
Queen d4 and real boy is not moving just
can't move can't do it doesn't know what
to do
it's definitely a difficult position for
black I think though you do more or less
have to to trade off these pieces here
because if you don't you're just gonna
end up getting getting a little bit
crushed and getting crushed by Geoffrey
Jean is never a fun time like what do
you do with this Queen if you don't
trade so yeah we do see the trade and
then black was thinking about his next
move with with age five age five looking
to lock this pawn on a dark square lock
this pawn on as a backward pond behind
the h4 pawn and get into some
comfortable endgame now though White's
advantage really comes from this d-file
pressure so Rick HD one does get played
it was like Bishop g5 could also be
coming on the board just to pick this
Knight out and allow the white rooks
into this seventh rank perhaps even be
five yes so ii v is Geoffrey's choice
taking more space and similarly kicking
this this night away
okay now Knight b5 looks to create some
pressure here some pressure on the a
pawn and especially some pressure with
96 okay rook d7 is coming now and I'm
starting to think black might be in in
some pretty serious danger some pretty
serious danger
it's not on a6 just leaves a very very
bad impression very bad impression okay
f6 was played f6 seems to make a threat
to the e5 pawn if you take this then II
five might give you some some trouble
there's f7 check King takes f7 or a d7
and then Bishop g5 to follow hmm looks
complicated looks like some complicated
stuff there simply rook e1 by by
Geoffrey I like the simple chess moves
in in this kind of time control here
where you don't have a ton of time now
Ricky seven might be allowing this move
he takes f6 followed by Bishop d6 when
this pawn is going to be a little bit a
little bit awkward
I guess rook e8 would would be
played there without too much
controversy how to improve with Jeffrey
how to improve he does take okay black
recaptures with the pawn of course
leaving this strong knight on g4 now
Bishop d6 the rook jumps back to EA as
expected
Enrique for I did not see the sideways
move rook a for now this should just win
a clean pawn and with the clean pawn I
think Geoffrey will win a clean game
once once you go down the pawn in this
end game your pieces were already worse
and if you get go down material as well
things just really start falling apart
night c7 now okay alright that's game
Geoffrey wins good talk everybody back
to dorsa house doors are doing
how is dorsa doing okay she started
pushing an ape on this isn't really an
idea I'm super familiar with she did
this in a previous game as well but she
just suddenly puts this pawn up to a
four it's kind of interesting though I
guess she's going after this pawn here
on a two moves like Knight before are
probably on her mind
I guess Queen B 1 is gonna be the
response protecting this a to pawn and
from there it'll be be a little bit
interesting to see what happens
once again C takes d4 is kind of just
waiting to be played but like doesn't
really have to play this move until
white is threatening the move d5 if
white can ever get d5 in comfortably
then black is going to be in a lot of
trouble so you have to keep an eye on t5
but if d5 isn't coming and you don't
really have to rush with C takes d4
things are fine so night before Queen B
one does come on the board here and now
what okay it looks like Geoffrey has
started the second game after winning
the round one that brings our total
score 2-2 Geoffrey one of the first
games to finish actually so let's see
what Geoffrey can do with the black
pieces looks like it was a French
defense
that followed this line that I have no
idea I don't know anything about this
line but it looks like things have
simplified a little bit so with things
being a bit more simple perhaps I can
determine the truth in the position also
taking a look around we have already won
one game on the bottom board as well so
we won on the top board one on the
bottom board great stuff Jenna Jenna
song winning that game so here what's
going on Black has more center pawns you
know you love to see more center pawns
for Jeffrey Shawn the unfortunate part
of it is White has a little bit of
pressure on this Kings side so White's
gonna look to generate some quick play
on the King side try to get at the black
King and black is going to look to get
this light squared bishop into the game
finished development and have this this
nice comfortable extra center pawn in
the meantime we won one more game
somewhere I'm trying to take a look
around see where that was it's tough
with 25 games to keep track of all this
but yeah our total score is up to three
it looks like Vinnie Vinnie won his
first game great job - Vinnie on one of
those middle boards so white castles the
move Knight takes e4 is pretty unnatural
now following it up with the other night
coming to f6 from there the move Bishop
d7 can be played along with Bishop ax up
to c6 and things are looking pretty nice
actually though hmm I'm not so sure
maybe the move b6 is more called for
here because if you do go in for this
line I just mentioned this fishable drop
back to d3 Bishop d7 you're allowing
allowing white this e5 square and I
really don't want to allow this square
to go to my opponent so the move b6 is
my new candidate move just bringing this
bishop out to be seven in the most
uncompromising way possible so b6 does
get played playing like Geoffrey Zhang I
love it I love it it's always a
confidence boost when you suggest a move
and then the 2700 player plays it you
know it's kind of nerve-racking to
commentate these games because you feel
just so inadequate compared to these
players
but yeah p6 seems good black is kind of
delaying castling if this bishop ever
comes out to be five this is probably
what Geoffrey is waiting for before
committing this King to the Kings side
just white wasting some time over here
trying to make use of the King on i-84
he he steps out of the way so I expect
white to develop this bishop now perhaps
to the g5 square trying to create some
threats and then we'll see we'll see
what Geoffrey has in mind I think just
Bishop b7 is going to be his his game
plan after this move problem is that
news do start to run into some
difficulties with Knight takes e4 so the
Grandmaster goes for Knight g5 instead
90 to g5 putting some pressure on f7
putting some pressure on e6 putting some
pressure on on h7 as well so this is the
type of position where Geoffrey Zhang is
going to calculate at the speed of light
and determine if there are any problems
with these sacrifices and then make a
decision based on what he calculates
there so let's try and calculate like
Geoffrey Zhang Bishop e7 is the natural
move h6 is also a pretty natural move
but with age 6 you're always giving your
opponent a little bit of a hook on h6
something white can latch on to to
sacrifice at a later date so let's stick
with Bishop b7 and this should be seven
let's say Knight takes c6 pawn takes c6
Queen takes c6 there there's a nice
Bishop d5 move really holding everything
together so I think that that is just
gonna be fine for black so I don't see
any problems I would have played Bishop
b7 there in this case though Geoffrey
does go for King side castles and now
undoubtedly white is looking to to
checkmate this king I don't see how
though I don't see how it happens one
move that black could or white could
maybe consider is a weird-looking move
like g3 the idea being you just want to
shake loose this nice queen on c7 with a
move like Bishop Bishop f4 but
I don't very much like that move to be
honest with you probably rookie one is
the most natural just piling up on e6
preparing a Knight takes c6 threat if
Knight takes c6 immediately is this
going to be a problem is this going to
be a problem I guess this is the problem
move to consider so ricky one instead
just kind of preparing it now I would
expect the move Knight c5 yeah 95
defends this so many times that you
never have to worry about it and
Geoffrey is looking to take off White's
powerful attacking Bishop here this
bishop dies then black should not really
have any problems in this position at
all instructive stuff from Geoffrey in
the meantime the score is now a whopping
8 to 1 we are crushing this tournament
or this match so far no the score to
beat so far is 29 from the Charlotte
Charlotte chess Center not the Charlotte
chefs Center see a knight c5 comes on
the board 95 now this is allowed by this
knight vacating d7 so what's the idea
well we can take off this Bishop I
expect Queen takes would be played
piling up on this square f7 is coming
under a little bit of fire so definitely
a lot of threats to still look out for
here so let's calculate Knight 63 Queen
takes d3 I was gonna play the move h6
afterwards so he plays h6 first daring
white once again to go in for some
sacrifices we'll see we'll see how brave
white is feeling we'll see how brave
white is feeling well he thinks about
that I will check on door sustain looks
like she is still on Game one here and
things have gone her way seemingly she's
up a pawn for the moment white has some
active rooks and is trying to regain
this pawn with some threats but yeah
dorsa up upon looking good so far okay
Bishop d4 I think worst case here dorsa
has to give up her extra pawn and
we'll be easily during the game though
King e6 is is really a nice move
ejecting that rook from its active
position so how do you hold everything
together here if your name is Dorsett
Derek Shani apparently rook c7 is how
you hold everything together I like it I
like it
we can check Julien's game - okay I'm
interested though I'm interested in this
checking back on Geoffrey it looks like
white was not feeling brave enough and
after age six simply came back then we
did see this trade on d3 and now there
should be seven so the fireworks have
kind of passed here white is still going
to go for some kind of attack over here
but Geoffrey is more or less solved all
of his his opening problems here so I
really like Geoffrey's chances now
checking in on Julien Julien has the
white pieces here and it looks like he's
up upon and has a pretty dominating
position moves like Knight f6 check are
already being considered I'm sure moves
like rook h6 are probably being
considered rook h6 actually looks quite
fun but unfortunately I think Bishop f5
would be good enough there rook b8 is
his choice that's an interesting one
that is an interesting one the idea is
if you take on b8 queen takes b8 and
then this is actually a pin on this
Bishop this Bishop moves you see Knight
f6 check and rotates d8 so the rook b8
creating some very concrete threats
against Blacks position here so we do
see the capture but now none of the
black pieces can really move and this is
more or less the the crux of the problem
here so King h8 steps out of these
checks
okay so black might be holding on for a
little bit just for a little bit now
what do we do with the white pieces here
well I think there's a lot of options
you can go for some types of end games
just up this extra pawn play moves like
rook d3 to kind of solidify I guess that
runs into Bishop f5 so Queen e5 is a
nice centralizing move stopping Bishop
f5 and now we'll see 93 and we'll
approach a a slightly more calm and game
position rather than a position where
white is
trying to checkmate with the extra pawn
this should be very comfortable for
right and more or less I think should be
winning I said all that and now is
Julian blundering upon no Queen III
defends everything okay friends
everything alright king b2 seems fine
seems fine
alright I will trust Julian to try and
convert this game here checking it on
Nick Rosenthal looks like unfortunately
he lost his first match so we won't look
at that one let's check in on Rachel Lee
Rachel Lee of course the terrifying
player who I believe is ten years old
now and is better at chess than me he's
better at chess than a lot of people and
it's gonna be better at chess and a lot
more people as time goes by she gets
better every month that goes by hmm okay
it looks like she's up to clean pawns
and should be able to convert this
position against you know some some you
know 2300 it's it's no problem of course
in our first match against San Francisco
she won 2 to 0 against an international
masters so I'm sure there's 2300 is
nothing but cannon fodder for Rachel Lee
rook d6 threatens checkmate Bishop f7 is
forced and now maybe just to move like
rook d7 with this coming - King f2
instead it's this rook the rook moves
everything checks out so far and now
Rick d4 to prevents a king f4 I don't
know if I love Rachel's technique on
this one I really like this idea of just
going right to d7 and forcing this
bishop away then coming in with with a
check is check here but okay rook d4
defends this pawn from behind and now
she is activating the bishop instead
okay rook h3 expect King G to throw a
cage for just King g3 and everything
stays defended now I expect to see him
move like rook F 4 and this pawn is
gonna start pushing up the board
or simply Bishop back to f3 Rachel
taking her time I trust that she will
convert this endgame though back to the
main show Geoffrey Jean here seems to
have gotten the Queen's off the board
and now the move f4 is on the board for
white I really don't like the inclusion
of this move it was probably played it
when Queens were still on the board
don't fact-check me on that one but with
the Queen's off the board this is just a
horribly weakening move the best-case
scenario is someday you get to play f5
and trade it off for this key six pawn
but you've already weakened it so much
around your king f4 just really hurts to
see I also want to mention that we are
absolutely destroying the Marshall chess
club it is 18 to 3 now 18 to 3 that's a
ridiculous score that is actually
obscene how many points were scoring
cupcake gets it done the Bensimon wins
his game PR chess 2016 whoever you are
won his game galaxy vs G Jacob Sanders
wins his game Aaron Lin wins his game no
shortcut win system scam Nick risco wins
vini wins hockey whoever that is Winton
that's Michael Pugachev Michael Pugachev
wins chess fans wins important pan
doesn't win but that doesn't matter
Lukie wins and we actually already have
a - Oh unforced errors won both of his
or her games Arjun want to know chess
playing wool from Danny Machuca want to
know Erik is one of our losses wolf team
2018 Rachel he actually drill Rachel
they drew that game Oh No Rachel should
have won that it was tough though it was
tough so it's now 20 and a half to four
and a half we won almost every game in
the first round with I think four four
exceptions which is crazy so we are
already on pace to destroy the match
score that Charlotte had against the
Marshall chess club and we're definitely
going to be looking to to win it all
here scoring so much early on is is
really really key here because once
again the final standings are determined
by your game scores not whether or not
you win the match but how many points
you score within
each match okay Jeffrey now is
attempting to win the game he went for
an interesting move g5 latching on to
that f4 pawn and now with this trade FG
h g his epon is actually just entirely
passed so now expect to see Geoffrey
play moves like king g6 and expect him
to go for f5 and f4 really breaking
through with connected passed pawns I
think this is more or less a great
winning plan rook d1 now is offering a
trade of the rooks honestly I think
Geoffrey can just go for this this rook
trade with the rooks off the board the
bishops are going to be even more
powerful and f5 and f4 seems incredibly
difficult to stop the bishops are gonna
rake across the board and this game is
gonna be just dead lost so I expect your
it takes d1 to happen twice and then
king g6 and then f5 and then f4 and then
this game is really just going to be
over I truly believe that what can white
do in the meantime
well we see the double Rick trade okay
Bishop a4 instead of king g6 and
Geoffrey instead of pushing these pawns
is simply winning more pawns on the
Queen side okay
Knight see Knight B to Bishop c2 hits
this pawn before is the plan and then
maybe Bishop e5 but Bishop g4 I think
it's time to fall back to plan a here
and just start pushing this guy this is
the thing to do definitely the thing to
do here okay there should be five though
Bishop d2 and now Bishop b3 so Geoffrey
just harasses these pawns even further
but yeah I think King g6 f5 and f4 is is
on the cards on the cards everything
else is kind of just marking time until
we get to this big plan
g4 instead I did not expect g4 I
expected
King g6 to support g5 and then f5 and
then f4 I'm not so sure not so sure
about this one
I mean obviously Geoffrey knows what
he's doing but this is not the plan that
would have seemed most natural to me so
blue right now is is making some threats
on the
inside making some threats if you play
the move b5 it's nights likely gonna
come back to eat 393 looks like a fork
at first Bishop d3 is kind of dominating
that piece really though maybe just
taking on a 5 makes sense but then the
night takes it's not so easy Bishop d3
threatens the knight it takes ba takes B
on the board and now Knight III must be
the move gotta be Knight e3 here or
maybe not but it's gotta be so Knight be
2 hits the bishop I don't like this
Knight as much on the b2 squared though
it just looks so awkward right looks so
awkward
okay so Bishop d5 and I think it's time
to fall back Geoffrey you got to start
pushing either this pawn of this pawn up
the board I think he might might just go
for a direct a pawn push white is is
doing some nonsense on the Queen side
and Geoffrey's trying to limit counter
play wherever possible but now the time
is right it's time for a move like a
five and it's time to get this King in
the game it's time to go time to go no
more patience in the meantime we've
bumped up our score to 24 and a half I
get to five and a half checking back in
on Doris's game she won that first game
I repeat she won her first game
incredible stuff winning in round one
and now she's trying to set up some
smothered mate cheapos but Knight a5 is
likely ruining those dreams by taking
off the lights great Bishop Queen h4 now
means there's a lot of pressure on age 7
and black is going to have to be very
careful about ever moving this night we
see takes and takes and now moves like
Bishop d4 are starting to come to mind
for Dorsett if you take on d4 well she's
gonna take on a h6 and it's looking like
checkmate in fact Bishop d4 immediately
might just be might just be crushing I
guess II 5 is playable but then Bishop
c5 in this pawn this point Falls got to
be Bishop d4 here will dorsa play it
will she find it Bishop d4 absolutely
crushing this game rook d5 instead I
really really think I really think
Bishop d4 just one okay
he's six hits this rook the rook full
retreats I assume maybe maybe she's
gonna get creative here Rick takes okay
now she plays Bishop d4 now she plays it
nice Bishop d4 by dorsa I don't know why
it was necessary to hang this rook first
but she felt that was the case so e5 no
Bishop c5 and this pawn just just gets
destroyed this pawn gets destroyed rook
have six even night b5 hits this pawn
again
d6 gets destroyed nice find by a by
dorsa rook f6 there's a fork there yeah
there's some sacrifices with like Queen
takes h6 but but even 95 is fine okay
now a rook takes d6 is pinning this
bishop likely rook or Bishop f6 is is
what white or black is is planning on on
banking on here okay rook F for now
interesting okay just Queen back to g3
it's tempting to look for like crazy
tactics here for for white this is not
playable due to the fork for counter for
Geoffrey just lost a pawn and we'll jump
back to Geoffrey here has he's in some
some time time trouble can you did in
fact lose a pawn but this is you know
big drop as they say big draw here okay
interesting
I don't think Geoffrey played this
endgame very well and I understand that
sounds a bit silly coming from me but I
really just don't think he played his
endgame well um here's how I thought
this endgame was gonna go I thought king
g6 was gonna be played white was gonna
play some move now this okay I'll play
better for white white is gonna try and
expand on this Queen side we're gonna
play f5 why it's gonna try to expand on
the Queen side we're gonna play f4 takes
takes bishop f2 and and this is crushing
this is what I thought was going to
happen in this game and unless I'm
missing some big resource for white I
think this is thus how the game should
have gone but I think Geoffrey would
have would have just killed him here but
I might be wrong on this one I've been
wrong before
in other news Nick Rosenthal battles
back in wins the second game in his
match let's check in on Julian pearl
Aiko who did manage to convert in Game
one and is looking at four more in Game
two
no we already have 29 points surpassing
the Charlotte chess center score against
the Marshall chess club if we score any
more points
a for singing yet I might have liked
blender something in that line that I
just showed unless you're talking about
a different position
okay sorry I was catching up on the chat
there what's going on in Julien's game
looks like some but no knee type of
stuff
why does seem to have a pretty good grip
on things for now it's the weird type of
Benoni where white actually got to
recapture it with the e pawn instead the
C pawn so things are gonna be slightly
different of course that means there's
no e 4 e 5 breaks for white but that
also means there's no pressure on the
e-file for black so now blacks probably
looking to make use of this e5 square at
some moment and probably continue with
things like f4 if if it's ever allowed
so 95 immediately would actually make a
threat of capturing and playing f4 but I
think white is looking to trade off this
dark squared Bishop if I'm 100% honest
with you I don't think that's a happy
piece over there I mean Bishop h6 there
if Bishop f4 g5 the official page six
actually looked like a quite good move
to me I think you're correct on that one
Talia I think you're correct
not sure what white would be doing
probably losing maybe just losing this
Bishop h6 winning might have been you
might have been a win with Bishop h6
okay though Julian's position actually
looks looks quite nice I I will give him
that Bishop h6 is once again going to be
a threat in this position as well okay
let's check back in who do you guys want
to check back in on dorsa let's see
what's going on with dorsa okay things
have progressed strangely where did all
the pieces go all the pieces died and
Orson's getting a queen trapped but
she's up a queen okay
she's up a queen here so that's good
Queen being trapped less good ninety
four though and while the Queen doesn't
really have any moves here it doesn't
really need any moves once the white
piece or once the black pieces moves the
Queen will have some squares so tonight
of five allows Queen h4 now and the
White Queen is the scaping
okay tics now takes and queen d8 check
is going to be a fork if you take on e4
this now f4 is hanging just take free
stuff take free stuff
take free stuff on f4 okay Bishop e5 now
what now what okay this game is a bit
silly to analyze Doris's up a queen
Doris is gonna win we're up to 32 points
against the Marshall chess club I
believe there are only 24 players in
this match as well leaving us with a
total of 48 points possible and we
already have 33 of them why don't we
check in on a slightly lower rated game
just for fun let's see how Danny Machuca
is doing Danny Machuca the chess playing
wolf with the white pieces here holding
on does he know his Philidor position
does he know it okay he's preventing the
pawn from pushing wait a second what's
going on here okay
this should be okay no no things have
gone wrong things have gone wrong but
it's a draw but it's a draw okay this
this I think be sixes is a win here
think be six and whites been embarrassed
but it seems to have been missed so
Danny Machuca getting a draw okay
jumping down to chest fence 2019 I have
no idea who this is but they're on our
team so well follow their game and it
looks like their game actually has the
furthest to go before it ends of most of
the games I've seen so far so I mean
pull up the standings again Queen f3 and
black is is kind of going all out here
all out for checkmate white is making a
queen rather quickly
rather too quickly for my taste but
black looking to kill them looking to
kill the guy with with some accurate
play here
okay
now Knight c3 comes on the board but you
know Queens are good you can't clean yet
with with wipes I guess you have to take
this Knights wait a second wait a second
wait Black is also down in exchange okay
black is not doing well this game are
there any other games left we can look
at Julian's still playing and Doris is
still playing while we stick with those
games okay Julian here does not seem to
have won the dark square bishop and said
having it traded off for his knight on
f7 now f4 comes on the board and what
now Bishop d4 check I assume I always
check it might be me
okay now Bishop d4 check does come on
the board Julie it's probably
considering taking this night off on c3
but I really don't like it just leave
this Bishop on d4 no reason to open this
B file for for white here moves like
Queen da also start coming to mind but
the idea of just harassing this a upon a
little bit gajillion trades off all the
rooks all the rooks come off the board
and now we have arrived at the end game
fun stuff so now Julian is likely much
more seriously considering taking on c3
following it up with Queen d8 you have
to defend this pawn somehow with white
so perhaps the move Queen a2 then you
can consider moves like b6 and Queen
takes b6 and black is just gonna have an
extra passed upon on the Queen side here
will it be enough to win I'm not so sure
okay Queen d8 comes on the board and
you're going to respond to check with
Bishop f7 now and this pawn is difficult
to defend difficult to defend
less space needs to keep the heavy
pieces I don't know I think Julian's
doing fine here
I think he's doing fine here okay so
Bishop d7 makes sense to guard these
scores he plays Bishop f7 instead I
think that's just a worse version
honestly you can't you still can't
really allow Queen East 7 so with what
Julian I'm expecting him to do is play
Bishop f6 play Queen takes a5 and just
go up a pawn here should be good
in the meantime dorsa did win her game
turns out having extra Queens is pretty
good and ends up winning that game
bringing our score to 36 out of 48 that
is a three to one advantage we have even
if we lose the rest of the remaining
games okay Bishop a4 is played now do we
tick I think just Bishop a f6 here
Bishop f6 seems simple you keep the
Queen out Bishop e8 though is the idea
okay I'm catching on you I'm a little
bit slow sometimes guys so King f8 stops
Bishop e8 and stops Queen e7 and now
Queen a5 is on deck here Queen I 5 on
deck to win this game Rachel Lee says go
black that's correct we are rooting for
Julian here rooting for Julian and I
think he's going to win this one all
right what else is going on here who
else is left still playing Rachel Lee
with two draws in her match against the
strong 2,300 let's see this chest fence
game is still going on and is that it's
there should be one more game in
progress somewhere that I'm not seeing
ah yes this one so let's see what's
going on here between a murder castle I
believe that's the forest and London kid
looks good forest he has an extra pond
is it enough to win the game maybe maybe
it is maybe it is white has a lot of
space on this Kings side moves like f4
f5 might create some awkward weaknesses
for black it does leave awkward
weaknesses behind for white though as
well so you got to be a little bit
careful here a little bit careful
just gotta be a little bit careful
okay rook b7 and now it's it's starting
to look pretty pretty silly King g8
means a check and then Rock f8 and this
is it's gonna be dead white picks up an
extra pawn it will win this game
checking back in somehow someway chess
fans is maneuvered into an exchange down
endgame he got rid of this 1/7 on
somehow which is a huge step forward but
this is is not going to not going to do
it for so we'll leave that game alot in
the meantime
Julian and making some progress here it
has picked off this a pond in the
meantime now this move would be a
mistake do take some giving a knight the
d5 square you could consider taking
twice though if you take twice and then
play King f6 then you can simply pick up
this pawn for free I think okay he's
going for b5 stuff now going for b5
stuff
okay now b3 it's getting a little bit
weird just be five just be five here
should do the trick
get active okay Bishop back to f7 I
don't fully understand what Julian's
going for here is he trying to just take
this bishop and take this pawn this is
not the way this is not the way I would
have done it I just like playing b5
keeping it simple just kind of expanding
over here on the queenside and winning
the game this wins another pawn though
this does win another pawn there's this
move in the ends I guess but it doesn't
really matter cuz the Queen side pawns
are too strong
and now Queenie for in this game is
nearing its end here game is nearing its
end b5 gotta play b5 at some point gotta
play b5 at some point I'd like it to be
now you can also play d5 here d5 might
be better I don't understand King Mesa I
don't understand what your Lane is doing
I don't understand a lot of things this
is one of them yes good games to dorsa
good games
taking age three stepping out of this
pin they should have six cards against
Knight g5 Julian's just taking it a
little bit too slow for my cases come on
just play like B [ __ ] or something I
don't have this kind of patience in my
life
b5 let's go alright h4 is is also a
winning I wasn't even looking at this
side of the board
but taking taking this guy off makes
sense b5 what's the weight what's the
big weight for here well what is what
are these moves what is Queen e6 what's
happening like they're not bad moves I
just don't understand them okay he was
worried about losing in this age pawn I
suppose so he brought the Queen back to
defend it can we play b5 now can we can
we please just play b5
hey maybe d5 here can we just play d5
okay what is what is the Queen doing in
g6 I don't understand what's happening
okay now all of a sudden white is is
quite active this is this is going
downhill
okay Queen takes f4 gives up the Queen
side pawns though but now maybe white is
is getting getting a little bit
checkmated hopefully please just a
little bit checkmate it okay this King
comes to g6 some more checks and
hopefully the wrong player doesn't get
checkmated here okay Bishop g7 no more
checks safe g7 safe now we see black
starting the check McQueen g4 picks up
the Knights and that should be the match
should be the match you can take this
night there's no perpetual the Queen and
the bishop can organize to stop the
checks he trades the Queen's off instead
also totally totally winning
okay one past fun coming on the board or
white here Julian is inside the box in
in time to stop it from queening and the
rest is history
okay one game left in the match nope
that is it the match is officially over
we crush the Marshall chess club
absolutely crush them
38 to 10 if that's not the highest
scoring match of this round-robin I will
be very surprised all right let's check
out how the Charlotte chess Center did
in their match let's see in round two
they looked to score 27 and a half
against the Mechanics Institute that
brings the total scores to let's see
what's our total score 38 plus 28
okay that is 58 plus 8 is 64 for the st.
Louis chess club 64 Charlotte chess
Center has 27 and a half plus 29 that's
49 plus 7 is 56 and a half then the San
Francisco Mechanics Institute
San Francisco seems to have what seat 20
and a half plus 20 is 40 point five and
then the marshal has 10 plus 19 is 29
these are your scores so far in the
final round 66 66 the dye account wrong
that I count wrong we have 66 this true
is this true is this true do we have 66
let me do some that let me do some math
here I already forgot our scores 38 plus
28 is in fact let's see 58 plus 8 is 66
66 for us use a calculator as too lazy
all right I'll just get it wrong so 66
for us I will amend yes I agree
so we have a whopping nine and a half
point lead going into the final round
nine and a half point lead so with that
in mind what score do we need to ensure
victory here the most that anyone can
score I suppose is 48 or 50
I think it's 48 now this seems to be the
running theme only only 48 total points
[Music]
but I don't think that's gonna happen so
let's say the most San Francisco could
possibly score is like 30 maybe 35 maybe
up to like 40 okay then we have a nine
and a half point lead against the
Charlotte chess center so nine and a
half means we can lose by nine games we
can go minus nine in this match and
still win so minus nine is is the goal
here meaning how many points are we
looking for
let's see 24 minus 9 we need like 15
points and I think we win which is a
little crazy maybe maybe more than 15
but 15 points seems seems pretty good ok
we need more than 15 points let's just
win this match and then I won't have to
try so hard with all this math ok the
last match should be just about ready to
get underway though so let me load it up
here ok here we have this final match
starting in 3 minutes and 35 seconds
starting in just a moment
okay and we have to score nineteen and a
half that's my final answer
forgot the x two so every point that we
lose is a point for them so every point
is kind of worth double so we need to
score at least 19 and a half in this met
in this match in order to guarantee
victory
so 19.5 is the magic number then I'm
going to shout and declare victory until
then we still have ourselves a match
you still have ourselves a match so it
looks like board 1 for the trial at
Charlotte chest Center is Daniel
Nowitzki wartooth seems to be an
international master I'm not sure
actually who this is
let's see if I can find out Carlos
Andres Perdomo Carlos Andres heard Elmo
on board - then board 3 seems to be Pete
Angie inaros I believe he's one of the
founders if not the founder of the
Charlotte chess Center up against Julian
Pro lekha see why don't we get 234 for
the round 100 that would be awesome but
so far things are looking quite good
well will there be a celebratory Skype
group call that's down to Mike comer
might come er the manager for this team
manager for most of our competitive
chess teams here so get in touch with
him regarding the celebratory Skype call
all right minute 45 to go minute 45
whoo all right it's been a marathon here
so far a marathon dorsa in the mean time
up against just kid who is a national
master can't trust that username though
kids are too scary so good luck to dorsa
playing a child
Rachel Lee also up against the national
master we'll see how she fares there the
meantime just looks like some pretty
even match ups down the board pretty
even stuff we do have a bit of an
advantage I think on these bottom boards
that's really where our team has been
shining we just clean up on these lower
boards after round two of three st.
Louis 68 Charlotte chess Center 59 1/2
San Francisco 40 and a half New York 29
there were forfeitures own disaster ok
so we have the totally accurate
scoreboard they're still 60 nope that's
to forfeit wins for us excellent
excellent stuff
okay ten so Aradia you didn't get to
play a last round but you still scored
two points for us on forfeit well done
and we are underway let's check in with
our board one here see how Geoffrey
Zhang fares against Internet aficionado
Daniel nerd it's key Danya of course has
been killing internet chess for some
time now breaking all sorts of raiding
records see how Geoffrey men just to
handle this
see how Geoffrey can handle this here we
have the old royal pence the old royal
apes' castles take some c6 take some c6
and now d3 okay white defending the
centre so this is of course the open
style of the Royal apes' wear white
eventually captures on c6 so we'll see
what Geoffrey can make of this position
yes the immortal Rebecca Harris with the
black pieces here one of Donna's many
internet usernames and yeah Daniel's
taking his time after d3 I'm not totally
familiar with all the theory in these
positions I'm not in the afore player
myself and it's not really for I don't
really respond to e4 with what the ROI
too often so I am in uncharted waters
for me although I'm sure many many many
chess games have found themselves in
this position before why don't we take a
look around no sorry I should have this
view up for you guys check in on doors
this game everybody loves doors that no
let's check in on somebody new let's
check in on my good friend Eric
tkachenko he is employed by this Chess
Club as a chess associate let's see how
he's doing here Bishop e2 seems to be
making some nasty threats to this Queen
on h5 stuff like 95 was threatened with
f3 and g4 to follow so Bishop g4 aims to
prevent some of those threats from
appearing and now what is Eric going to
do it's tough to make concrete threats
here it's tough to decide what white
wants to do with this King actually he
might go for some trades with something
weird like 91 and recapturing you might
also play a move like d3 I don't really
like the move T for Queen c2 also comes
to mind with the idea of queenside
castling but it looks a little bit
awkward here for Eric if I'm under
present honest yeah time to go for some
trades I think Knight g5 going for some
trades
going for some trains from the g5 okay
not going for all the trades though
ninety-two I think Eric is committing to
trying to track this Queen f3 now I
would not be surprised to see him play
with the full commit to the Queen trap
I don't think f3 is a good move though
because the Queen does have the h6
square it's a little bit difficult to to
get at that Queen with that type of
shelter I also am NOT a huge fan of
Eric's position here it might be time to
just play a move like Knight f4 and
honestly get these Queens off the board
get these Queens off the board you do
have to look out for some tactics like
Knight e4 coming up in later positions
with the discovered attack on the bishop
but I think if air can get these Queens
off things are gonna be a little bit
more comfortable
ripsi one might be coming as well with
some pressure here I don't think things
are terrible for Eric but just a little
bit wonky just a little bit wonky and
night before it could be a threat that's
kind of why I like those Knight f4 move
you're keeping an eye on d3 and you're
offering up this this Queen trade okay
we'll leave Eric to it
Danya has made quite a bit of progress
in his game so as Talia correctly said
the ideas are 97 f6 and bringing this
knight to e6 it went pretty much exactly
as she said it would Knight f5 and we do
see this light square bishop come off
the board to take off the powerful
knight on f5 now the e6 square is a
little bit defended so 96 probably not
gonna come on the board now expect
Geoffrey to play moves like like f4 I
think f4 in the future is how white is
going to look to break down blacks
Center and even though I just said that
I do like not playing at 4 for a long
long time this pawn is almost really in
blacks way cutting off these jerks from
getting in the game cutting off this
Bishop from any open diagonals and
I think Jeffrey has a pretty nice hold
on this position right now Queen f7 is
defending a little bit on the Kings side
a for Jeffrey just takes some space
takes some space okay I am looking for
stupid tactics like this Jeffrey Zhang
is probably thinking more about the
strategical features of the position and
not cheap form of long tricks that don't
even work okay now I'm really thinking
about my cheap form move trick in the
meantime though
Danya is probably trying to break out
with moves like g6 so Queen h3 and I
just I want to this is what I want
that's what I want out of life that's
all I want out of life Knight f3 Knight
age 496 of course there are practical
problems with it the h5 pawn hangs after
you play Knight g4 and Jeffery is of
course just playing very professional
chess doubling on the e-file preparing
to make some threats
okay now h6 is trying to slow down the
white players attack here Knight f3 does
come on the board and I'm still looking
for stuff like this
Geoffrey might be looking at this move g
v g5 does start to look pretty
attractive here the idea being if you
take with the H upon H 6 is gonna come
with pretty strong force and if you take
with the F pawn while you're leaving
behind this pawn on e5 I don't think
tactically it's going to work out
immediately but definitely this is
something on Jeffrey's mind so moves
like that h4 + 96 can also come the
board the black king is going to hide on
h7 it's just a matter of finding a way
to break through with white here don't
forget though moves like f4 are going to
to be on the cards for Geoffrey and he
really I keep saying the word cards he
holds all the cards here as well it's
really Geoffrey who can decide when he
wants to open up the position efore is
really the only way for black to take an
active approach to the position trying
to break things open with a move like
efore but if you give Geoffrey some time
I think Knight age 4 is going to be
played and a move like f3 would would
actually just stumped
efore idea I did just say that moves
like f3 would stunt the before idea but
I'm not convinced I like the move f3 so
let's not play it that in mind this is
the only break that white really has to
worry about
so King h7 preemptively stepping out of
any Knight g6 checks not a bad idea
Knight age 4 anyways and like I said
before is the only way for black to try
and get active here so Danya just taking
a purely defensive approach with Knight
f7 if this night lands on g5 it's gonna
get taken off the board so I don't
really expect it to to make it that far
96 is playable perhaps Geoffrey wants to
leave the knight on h4 Bonet on IG 6 now
Bishop d6 is keeping an eye on things
and this night like I said just a purely
defensive role keeping an eye on these
squares making sure no funny business
happens and yeah the eventual f4 is
still going to be coming it's just a
question of is it enough to play for for
an advantage here I'm not super certain
I expect now move Queen e2 looking for
some of these squares squares on the
Queen side and yet it does get played
and it's really just down to uh to what
white can do here Danya definitely not
playing for a win here the only way
black ever wins these games if is if
white goes crazy and tries to over press
which of course is something that's been
known to happen in chess games before
but like I said Geoffrey holds all the
call cards here he's gonna be the one to
decide when things open up
so yeah Bishop d2 is a prophylactic move
guarding this key Foursquare and how to
organize the white pieces to break
through that's going to be the game here
black is I think in Zook Swann I think
these are the best squares for danya's
pieces and now you have to move one of
them so Queen c8 a slight deep route
meant of the black pieces but nothing to
really do here for black besides these
awkward passing moves okay I expect now
a move like Bishop c3 to come on the
board
the idea being you just want to set up
this f4 threat
and be able to actually win upon on e5
and how do you stop you takes f4 well
hopefully you get enough pressure on
this efile so that it takes up four is
never an option due to some hanging
pieces on e it so I want to move like
Bishop c3 then let's say black passes
then I want to move like f4 sorry not
like f4 then I want to move like
bringing this Queen in and then maybe
after a queen trade to move f4 and and
going for the win so Queen c4 now
Queen c4 Jeffery just placing his pieces
on active squares and now Tonya is
finally attempting something explain c6
I don't know if he's actually going to
play the move b5 or not I suspect he
isn't I think c6 is just to guard these
light squares a little bit more
thoroughly and now f4 has been played
this is the break f4 now Bishop c3 to
follow and that's a lot of pressure on
e5 that is a lot of pressure I am not
convinced that black is going to be able
to hold here so b5 was prepared with
Queen b7 now the a pond is in fact
hanging so black has to do something on
this Queen side either takes which looks
horrible or b4 which looks horrible or
c4 which looks horrible that's a free
pawn that's a free pawn that's a free
pawn I'm taking it
this is dunya's idea thank okay so he
takes b5 instead this also makes a ton
of sense
totally fracturing the black pawns here
I think Jeffrey's winning think Jeff is
winning
yeah I'm not sure 95 is too big of a
threat though Thalia it does look like
though you did play f4 pretty quickly
after removing this Bishop from from d2
or no he only played a bishops III after
f4 so he did always keep an eye on this
g5 square now Queen c4 is offering a
queen trade and just going in for some
endgame where he's looking to to take on
e5 an interest win I think take c5 is is
called for now oh yeah this pawn is
hanging I forgot so Geoffrey is just
winning all the pawns and he's gonna win
this game these two pawns are horrible
White has the view of most beautiful
endgame I've ever seen and he's winning
upon on on e5 as well this was a real
crush from Geoffrey a real crush from
Geoffrey here
I mean he doesn't have to take honey
okay he does take an e5 I thought it was
about time I thought it was about time
now how many pieces does he trade here
zero one two or like a billion tough to
tell
looks like the Knights come off and the
bishops come off and the rooks come off
and the extra pawn is in Jeffrey's hand
after takes or maybe he won't take maybe
moves like Queenie four are crossing his
mind it was like Queenie six as well
just to welcome you six means Queen d4
so not that one but I expect to Ricky
five here just just take take stuff take
free stuff the problem is is going to be
the the King's safety here that's gonna
be Donna's saving grace if you can find
one note we are actually tied four to
four so far Julia pearl echo quickdraws
and both of his games agreed to a draw
with white here and then let's see with
black looks like he agreed to a draw
here so that is just good match strategy
from Julian we have the lead going into
this mesh so every draw just brings us
closer to securing that title so two
draws from him not upset about at all
Danny Machuca is actually already won
his game
Dominic Colombo I don't know who that is
the real MC has won his game
Lukie has Oh Dominic is playing for the
Charlotte chess center that's why I
don't know who it is
Lukey unfortunately lost in round one
michael Pugachev lost in round one
unfortunately PR chess lost in round one
Nick risco winning in round one as well
as cupcake cupcake winning in round one
as well Jenna Goes Down and the
Charlotte chess center has taken the
lead now five to four five to four sorry
let's go back to a real game still in
progress Jeffrey does just take on the
e5 square okay
and things went wrong for Eric in that
game that we were looking at as well
Eric did end up losing that position and
dang in the Charlotte chess center in in
the lead by two points now of course we
win we win the the entire tournament if
we get anything better than a nine-point
deficit in this match against Charlotte
but of course we're the st. Louis chess
club you know we're looking to win every
every match so gonna be kind of a
bittersweet victory if we don't manage
to beat Charlotte here it'd be a
bittersweet victory okay Brooke c1 Danya
just trying to string together some
threats now but it's it's really not
gonna happen it's really not gonna
happen against Jeffrey Shawn even the
move rookie two could be played here my
idea is I simply want to play Queenie
six Queenie six threatens checkmate with
Queen g6 and Ricky eight and if you
trade the Queens well it's a rook end
game down - and really essentially three
ponts and so that is going to be a dead
victory so I like the move rookie - here
for Jeffrey just simplifying things
getting into a totally what is this why
would you give this pawn okay Jeffrey
goes for checkmate instead he's a more
ambitious chess player than me so
Queenie for King f3 and then f6 is going
for some checkmates that's not how but
but this is how stuff like this and
queen g6 is getting the job done
looks like unstoppable mate or at least
you know winning winning a queen same
thing same thing here it's now 8 to 5 8
to 5 in this in this match you're
curious Queen d4 might be trading the
Queen's though so maybe this is how how
Danya doesn't lose immediately with
Queen d4 no King g8 instead so f6
would mean what f6 would mean takes but
then check I'm so confused f6 looks
crushing f6 looks crushing Geoffrey
Zhang of greens agrees Geoffrey Zhang
agrees f6 looks crushing and this is
this is gonna be this gonna be this
gonna be the game why don't we check in
on dorsa who won her first game nice
dorsa winning her first game looks like
yeah black just resigns here this pawn
is not going to be stopped this Bishop
does an excellent job escorting us pawn
all the way down the board stopping this
knife from coming b6 stopping the
circuit from guarding b8 and that is the
match well done - dorsa winning in Game
one
yeah and now Danya has officially
resigned
bringing the match score up to 8 to 6
it'll update momentarily I'm sure and we
are in Game two between
Jeffrey Zhang and Danya and uh-oh
Charlotte has actually gone up to ten
points now a four-point deficit already
we gotta we gotta get there somehow this
is not going the way we wanted it to go
and oh my gosh and peachy and Otto
speeds forest
disaster on that board things are are
going wrong these lower boards where we
redid so well they're they're starting
to swing the other way starting to swing
the other way Bensimon though holding
strong for the st. Louis chess club wins
his match against Jeff P 22 all right
Danya just going for a simple type of
opening where you play Knight c3 before
moving this pawn I don't like this style
of opening play this Knight just feels
out of place on c3
some of the the ideas involve having a
quicker
support of this movie for also more
ideas involving this move Knight b5
rep this is the advantage to leaving
this pawn back on on c2 I just don't
like it though
just in general I'm not a huge fan so
takes c5 now ninety-seven like doesn't
really want to waste time with
recapturing this pawn directly moves
like Queen a5 also come to mind for
black just piling up on this night so
now Knight takes e5 it's Bishop is hits
and Geoffrey will be taking off the
light squared bishop here
or for white this LightSquared bishop is
always a powerful piece in these d4
openings and so getting rid of it is a
pretty nice achievement for Jeffrey in
fact you might now be fixing his worst
minor piece by trading it for whites
best minor piece always fun stuff how we
doing
well it was looking rough there for a
second board we're staging a comeback
here up to 12 to 10 up to 12 to 10 I was
just talking about how you know we we
need less than a nine and a half point
deficit to win the entire tournament but
that doesn't mean we don't want to crush
the Charlotte chess Center as well in
this match so looking to win this match
what can you win smash now it's 13 to 10
Charlotte yeah but these lower boards
are where they're killing us we need to
start winning games on these lower
boards cupcake cupcakes my favorite
player in the entire match all she does
is win so cupcake still holding strong
for us Michael Pugachev also bailed back
in the second game he lost in round one
but managed to win in round two
excellent Arjun scoring a solid draw
that gets us closer to the threshold we
need which I believe is nineteen and a
half if we get to nineteen and a half I
think we win by force yeah I appreciate
it the two professional draws from
Julian getting us closer to winning the
entire tournament
just taking the draws Eric what a piece
Eric's up a piece in his game we gotta
check it out gotta check it out Knight a
five hits the Queen hits the night this
night is falling off the board well done
Eric so Eric battling back Eric battling
back this is what we need to do these
players who lost in round one can't give
up just yet who is cupcake I knew who
cupcake was at some point in my life but
now she's just cupcake to me so that's
that's all I know
let's see cupcake is Isabelle Isabelle
okay well King f8 is on the board how
did this happen did I miss something
okay 96 is a check okay so this is how
he
the piece okay now Rick see one Eric up
a piece but with a weak King so what
does that mean for this game means Eric
has to be careful knight c6 now it looks
very natural you just block off this C
file support your Center threaten things
like 95 and Knight takes f3 it's time to
start consolidating with the black
pieces you have this extra extra piece
so you just need to get safe and get
pieces off the board and get closer to
just a technically winning endgame
that's the way to go with black hair
green comes back to b3 but this is kind
of a silly piece at this point moves
like Knight e4 are potentially playable
now with this Queen vacating the center
at 92 looks like a threat 95 is of
course the main threat so looking really
good for Eric in this game looking
really good
94 you might run into some trouble with
Bishop f4 actually you might have to be
a little bit careful with with that one
so if I'm Eric I'm playing moves like h6
I think okay there's just these problems
with with these Center pawns might have
to give some material back with black
here I wouldn't mind it at all moves
like rook da also come to mind just
guarding the center okay how is Geoffrey
doing in this game let's check back in
this is the main game we're following so
I was saying he's getting rid of White's
best minor piece and he does just that
okay now the bishop on b4 was hanging so
Knight a6 defends also defends 97 also
defends but 96 and this is just going to
be a really solid position before
Geoffrey here really no worries for
Geoffrey strong in this position with
the LightSquared Bishop off the board
these positions become so much more
pleasant for black and fan white because
without this piece white is missing so
much pressure on all of these squares on
both sides of the board this is kind of
like I talked about this so often I talk
about in my lectures all the time this
is a critical critical piece for white
in any d4 structure and without it on
the board it's it's gonna be tough for
white to to prove anything
gonna be tough for white yeah Danya now
trying to come up with a move moves like
Bishop c5 are probably probably coming
soon for Jeffrey then it can just start
to reorganize the pieces Queen out to be
six
rooks over to DA and get this Knight
back in the game was something like
night before so
Danya plays immediately with the move c4
making immediate threats in the center
Geoffrey could capture this if he's so
desirous or come up with something else
moves like Bishop c5 still seemed good
if Queen c3
for example rook c8 and you're not very
happy taking this piece taking this pawn
rather and getting this knight on to the
d5 square and that's what Geoffrey goes
for so if Queen c3 I would expect rook
c8 now even 94 is playable
if Queen c3 so that's why Queen d3 comes
on the board but now night before hits
this Queen and then Knight c3
is coming or 94 is coming in anyways so
Queen b3 avoiding the c3 square not
allowing the knight to come with tempo
it makes a lot of sense Queen b6 might
potentially be playable here keeping an
eye on this night here on b5 White's
next move is is likely a three I'm just
curious what if the move a5 comes on the
board for black here if a3 a4 if Queen
c3 94 things are starting to look almost
tactically winning for Geoffrey Zhang
unless unless white kind of just bails
out and takes on d5 rook c8 and set a
good solid improving move by Geoffrey
the score is 14 to 14 now we have
leveled the match we have levelled the
match and here who might shouting out
for to thank for leveling this match
important pen goes to and OH in his
match important important pan portent
scores by an important pan chess playing
well Dani Machuca 200 is his opponent 15
to 15 now oh boy 15 to 15 so Dani
Machuca coming in strong for the st.
Louis chess club here with the - Oh
Rachel Lee of course crushed her
opponent no surprise there all Rachel
Lee does is win chess games
checking back in on dorsa here she of
course won in round 1
now we're looking at her round 2
position as Queen d3 checkmate Nachi 4
is what's what is happening what is what
is happening what is happening what is
what is happening
III oh my gosh III oh my gosh dorsa
going wild on the chessboard this is
crazy stuff
III giving up this Bishop on g7 this is
brave stuff from dorsa this is brave we
have to see the conclusion of this game
this is this is too wild this is too
wild III and it's it's a really strong
fork and it looks looks like checkmate I
hope I hope it looks like checkmate
gosh so III eat takes F 2 is coming then
I'll move like Bishop e2 is gonna be a
check and move like Queen D 3 is gonna
be checkmate eat XD 2 is the exact same
threat this this is the the forced
checkmate sequence and that dorsa saw so
how do you stop it with black is with
white is the question and I'm not
convinced that you do the move Bishop e5
could be tried but then simply take some
takes is also going to be killer I think
this is this is just dead Knight e4
means he takes f2 and you can't
recapture with the night due to the pin
and your King can't move so that's
losing a queen
ok looks like a win for dorsa I'm
calling it they're back to Jeffrey's
game he's running a bit low on the clock
how did this pan out so a 693 and then
Geoffrey did capture on c4 ok now it
just brings this night into d5 and the
black pieces seem to be pretty
coordinated here simple moves like rook
d8 can just be played now challenging
this rooks claim to the D file Geoffrey
could also consider taking on c3 with
the idea of bringing the second night
back into into into d5 but yeah I like
rook da
I like Rudy it
oh sorry it Julie mentions an important
move that I did not mention if F takes e
where's the mate well Rick takes III
King D one bishop here King C - Queen D
3 is checkmate you could probably play
Queen D 3 first as well but you can do
it with check I believe the score is now
17 to 16 in favor of the Charlotte chess
Center this is close
Jenna battling back in her second game
winning on the lower lower board what
else Ben Simon
like I said won his first game let's see
how Ben Simon's doing in the second game
Ben Simon in the chess960 aficionado
winning the first ever st. Louis Chess
Club viewer tournament in a tournament
with over a hundred and twenty players
Ben Simon getting first place beating
out Jonathan Israel door Sedaris Shawnee
combo for first place incredible stuff
Ben though Oh No Ben's killing it I
thought Ben had wait for a second but
Ben has black tennis Killian
this pawn is more or less indefensible
white has to try crazy stuff like efore
you can take and then Bishop c1 but this
is just garbage then this rook can never
move and the game is going to be over
now Knight takes b2 is is just crushing
now you takes b2 and black is winning
this chess game go Ben Simon go Ben
Simon
okay back to Geoffrey Zhang back to
Geoffrey Zhang I keep jumping around a
lot okay Knight d6 is offering up two
pieces for the rook here with the idea
of being Queen takes b7 is going to
follow is that worth it I remain
unconvinced
if Geoffrey doesn't like it then the
move Knight a5 good appear move Knight
a5 might be a good move anyways but then
then Queen a3 I suppose then things get
a little bit weird with with Bishop b8
there things just get a little bit weird
a little bit weird so rook takes c6
Bishop takes d6 Queen takes Queen takes
b7 and what's going on the safest move
feels like it's probably Knight d2 e7
in that position when everything seems
to be holding together there's no back
rank checkmate and Jeffrey should be
consolidating with the two pieces for
the rook quote unquote advantage but
then Queen takes a six and moves like
Queen d2 it just gets a little bit crazy
white gets both of these pawns is the
point and the black Queen might get
active though so I'm not so sure it's
looking quite complex here Jeffrey Zhang
taking his time down to 45 seconds
though he's gonna have to play a move
he's going to have to play a move he
takes he goes for it
I love it Queen takes b7 he does go 497
and then like I said Queen takes a6 I
can Queen d2 I think Queen d2 is is
Jeffrey's idea here hitting this pawn
hitting this night which is defended
touching this trick as well just just
touching all the white pieces touching
all the white pieces dorsa to an O with
the killer III tactic we saw that one
live on stream dorsa we saw that one
live on stream Knight g4 III crazy stuff
what a game what a game okay Queen d2
I'm playing like Geoffrey Zhang how do I
do it I'm the best
okay so moves like rook takes c6 fail to
checkmate this pawn is currently hanging
so that's probably the threat that Danya
is thinking about now play like a b3 I
guess it just doesn't feel feel good
playing the move b3 doesn't feel good
I want moves that feel good maybe Queen
b7 but that hangs a knight so can't do
that
still no background check me because we
have this b8 Square covered
it's starting to look a little bit tough
for Danya this this is a pretty weird
configuration of the black pieces but it
seems to hold everything together these
two knights defend each other and the
bishop and without many pieces left on
the board for Fred Anya it's tough to
make threats against this structure so
h3 allows Queen takes p2 and but then
perhaps Tania's playing as Rick takes c6
takes takes and takes you can't take the
knight do to checkmate
so simply age six in return from Jeffrey
Shaun makes a lot of sense no back rank
mates in this game Eric is done did Eric
win did Eric win he did win up a piece
Eric we saw you winning that piece
tactically congratulations the score is
now 21 to 19 with just a half more point
we actually guarantee that we get 1st
place in the entire tournament but we
want more of course we want to destroy
with Charlotte chess Center so rook
takes c6 no I don't understand this can
be captured
now but then Queen ticks and this bishop
is is dying this bishop is dying not
ideal
there's Queenie one Geoffrey Zhang is
out of time you got to play a move Jeff
got a play move it's called called him
Jeff Flake he's my bud this move is
check got a play got a play Geoffrey
takes this move is still checked he just
takes the knight ok now Queen a8 I
expects takes the bishop and Geoffrey
takes on beats who takes an F to send
game doesn't look pleasant the send game
doesn't look Pleasant some game as many
things pleasant is not one of them
maybe f6e 5 H 5 looks lost
this looks lost unfortunately 22 and a
half to 19 and a half now
well things are going wrong cupcake
failed me cupcake was like my ace in the
hole Bensimon winning both of his games
good job Ben it's getting getting close
here I think there's only I think twenty
four and a half secures the the victory
for Charlotte so they just need two more
points here Donny wins this game then
they just need one more point okay
this threatens perpetual check good now
Donna has to stop this this move stops
it I suppose but then f6 then Queen c7
thinking g6 and then he five and then
this move anyways I don't know I just
don't know
Jeffery making some problems for Daniel
year making some problems Rachel Lee is
still playing oh well Rachel's playing
though that's a free point for us so
perfect let's check in on her okay maybe
not a free win for us this is looking to
be rather rather dryish but you know I
don't doubt that Rachel could pull off a
W here I don't doubt it back to
Jeffrey's game though I'm invested so H
for it just comes on the board so let me
flip that and you Queenie v seems like
the best move I don't know what else
Danya could really play here besides
Queenie v Queen d one-stops perpetual
but then Queen takes B - you push this
guy I'll come here so he gives this
check instead
f5 now yeah f5 and now Queen f3 okay
this was this was the point oh and Danya
Danya seems to have found found a line
here okay wait what it was stop doing
that okay this moves check white wins by
resignation
oh this moves check but then that move
his check dang all right Jeffrey Jean
going down in the second match here so
that brings Charlotte to 23 and a half
they need one more point they just need
one more point to secure victory in this
game let's check in on the next highest
board I believe this is forest up
against Pete gia nachos
Forrest seems to be trying to checkmate
black with the few remaining pieces on
the board okay you can take this pawn or
you can push maybe just push yeah just
push it push it to the limit so he
pushes it looks like he's going to be
winning some material King d5 seems like
the best move to keep an eye on Rexy for
King takes instead okay uh and now now
this pawn falls okay this seems to be
under control still for four black under
control in fact is it worse than under
control is white losing we might be
losing
yikes big yikes big that's it that's a
hefty Ickes from me if if why it loses
this game that's a hefty yikes the rough
g4 must have been missed I think King d5
was required I think King d5 was
required that's a good find
from from PG and out of Syria c7 isn't
enough this is check that move is also
checked now this move is check
oh but 98 mm King use up okay
and I believe Charlotte has secured
victory in this match with 24 and a half
points however we have secured victory
in the entire tournament with 21 and a
half so that is a secure victory for the
st. Louis chess school I believe we have
secured first place in this tournament
and as expected Rachel Lee is holding
just fine here so that will likely bring
at the score to 22 to 25 and then there
should be one more game in progress
somewhere looks like chess fans 2019 is
still playing chess fans 2019 on our
team looks like he's playing for a win
he's got some good passed pawns here on
the Queen side we're looking to make use
of those okay Queen afore you can take
this pawn now there's a check but 98 is
is holding fine
okay check 98 and this move threatens
checkmate be careful okay just Queen g6
can't take care of this check and now
black is just pushing the pawns I love
it
just push the pawns just push the pumps
check okay didn't insert the accurate
check still some more work to be done
here up the clean piece Queenie it is
nice
Queenie four is a check things are
looking pretty good I like the check
kingi it doesn't make so much sense your
King needs need some shelter behind
these pumps okay is he blocking with the
night no he's blocking with the Queen
just come back to h8 buddy hey it's
better
h8 is better just come back over just
get back over there okay don't repeat
moves okay clean e8 instead King it's
not f8 oh my goodness oh boy alright not
the most accurate way to escape the
checks the King on g6 should be safe as
well because the Queen can guard this
diagonal and now we have check okay now
this is easy this is easy no more Queens
on the board no more checks
save your knight and win this game save
your knight and win the skin just don't
trade too many pawns don't trade too
many pawns
okay that moves a check just bring the
knight to e3 now Perfect's bring the
knight f1 hit this guy
and then king out for King King f5 seems
fine just came out five perfect g4 will
take it and then King g5 and we're
easily picking up that last pond
can we take King g5 then wetter where
this King goes we have some way to pick
up this phone now and Knight takes pawn
and that'll be the match that'll be the
match Rachel Lee as expected somehow
managed to win this completely drawn
wreck endgame looks like she did it by
attacking a rook and then taking her up
well done to her so that brings the
final score of this match against the
Charlotte chest Center 225 223 so we
don't get the super clean sweep but we
do get clear first place in this
tournament clear first place good stuff
and also actually there might be some
forfeitures there might be some
forfeitures here I don't know the
details but if Charlotte failed to field
a twenty-fifth player then I believe we
get some points by it by forfeit maybe
we get some points by forfeit because it
looks like our twenty-fifth player
didn't actually get to play so we might
have the best kind of victory the
victory by default incredible there's
some Homer Simpson quote that I won't
I won't force upon you guys okay back to
the only last game in progress here
sorry I stopped looking at it because
black is queen and black is now just
going to checkmate
the white king
and that'll do it that will do it nice
rally from Charlotte to be sure okay
so I believe that actually puts
Charlotte in the interesting position
where they won all three of their
matches but we scored more match points
so we are in fact the champions and in
fact actually and the final score is 23
and a half to 24 and a half which if
mathematicians out there are aware it
does not add up to 50 this is supposed
to be a 25 player match so Charlotte was
missing a player I believe that means we
win this match byah by default as well
yes Eric we did in fact definitely win
the entire event st. Louis chess club
getting first place in this one
definitely definitely no way we didn't
no way we did
thank you to suva thank you thank you
okay well I think that just about does
it for us here then thank you all very
much for joining me for this incredibly
exciting match between three other chess
club's spread throughout the nation I
had a lot of fun commentating on all
these games we have some really great
players in the event they played some
really impressive chess so a great job
to everyone involved on the st. Louis
side thank you to all these other chest
centers for getting involved in these
online matches we're having a lot of fun
with them hopefully you guys at home are
enjoying them as well and with that in
mind my name is Caleb Denby this has
been a big online round-robin between
the st. Louis Chess Club that we ended
up scoring first place